hi hi we are the cast of oceans 8 and we
are going to play a game called never
have I ever
oh okay you ready have you ever done a
game before ever have you have not
questioned yeah have you ever gambled
who has what literally your love have
you ever been ambled with your love ever
played cops and robbers as a kid okay as
a sex game Cate Blanchet two-time Oscar
winner have you ever played cops and
robbers with your husband after the kids
went to bed okay Shira Bullock yeah you
played cops and robbers no don't never
have I ever taken someone's clearly
labeled lunch paulsen I haven't never
have I ever wanted to ask Rihanna
while we're shooting she wanted to hang
out afterwards oh oh we did we hung out
with her you don't we all did finding
your violin so never have I ever used
something and returned it yeah wonder
where all the time we've really cut this
part out all right
never never got off a random exit or
made a random turn to lose a cop oh
hello oh I 8585 an is how I eat BQE
there's a warrant out for your arrest is
it ever have I ever had an escape plan
even for a date
you wouldn't be even for a day you've
all you've been with your husband since
you reach puberty so you can't really
answer this so why don't we just talk to
people who had a date like it states not
going well my partly oh my
was the worst thing you did on a date to
escape it crying good been to a premiere
or done a red carpet without any
underwear off no no neither never have I
ever plotted a crime in my head oh well
have you ever plotted a good crime to
kill yeah we get it you're gonna have to
kill we're not promoting ladies suck it
up we have a film to sell and she's the
team leader we get it we thank you for
spending time with us we hope you come
see ocean Saint June 8th in theaters
near you
[Music]